all right hey what's going on everybody
its bill burr and it's time for the
thursday afternoon just before Friday
Monday morning podcast dad just check it
in on you I'm just checking in on your
week here right now usually you know
what do I usually do I usually sit here
my [ __ ] pajamas I [ __ ] you know
I'll give you a little half-hour of
[ __ ] [ __ ]
to tell what it's payday right you don't
need a full show you have probably half
in the bag in a [ __ ] El Torito at
this point if you listening to it you
shouldn't be driving but every once in a
while I do have a guest I do have a
guest and today we have the great Joe
Rogan [ __ ] grand national champion at
Taekwondo sitcom star [ __ ] reality
show a commentator right across the way
L Connor wild boar hunter [ __ ]
conspiracy theory [ __ ] whatever you
want this guy is his own [ __ ] entity
and he has a brand new killer special on
Netflix entitled triggered please
welcome Joe Rogan thanks Bill burns
going on long time coming to him I know
I love your show I have laid on mind a
bunch time so I'm gonna be on your but
you're a big like interview guy I'm I'm
like a [ __ ] lunatic who just sits in
the corner of his house and everyone
said while my wife walks by and I love
the style that you do because it's very
unique you know I've done a couple like
that where I answer questions stuff like
that but it's a very unique style of you
know you yeah I think it lends itself
really well to stand up and to
developing bits to I just didn't want to
deal with having a like book like you're
fine you're simply okay come down to my
studio perfect
you don't have me but like I just didn't
want it I saw what other people were
going through like oh I got an audition
can we make it four o'clock and I was
just like I don't want to [ __ ] deal
with that stuff but but when I if you
know if everyone could be a guest like
yourself can I start with the elk thing
yeah because I am fascinated with
hunting I think it's badass I think
everybody should know how to do it and
and I'm not one of the I am an animal
lover but I'm not going to be that
hypocritical one that [ __ ] eat
chickens that had their [ __ ] beaks
clipped off and they got the the
roided-out my
McGuire breastplate and they're tipping
over and the coupe's all that [ __ ] that
you see and then I'm gonna be good look
could you shoot a [ __ ] pheasant or
whatever hell you're shooting out there
but um yeah i retweeted a picture of you
got this was it you said it was a
12-point or why do you say six at six by
six they call it a straight [ __ ] excel
it's a six by six I sent me this big elk
that was the I've shot three up that's
the biggest one by far that one was
monstrous was huge so what is yeah this
is the thing that always fascinates me
about hunting shows is the nervousness
and the whispering before you take the
shot boys like okay there it is yeah
okay exhaling just like if you miss I
mean it's the [ __ ] thing gonna come
running at you know it seems like cuz it
does I'm not to spook it because you
have to have it close enough for you to
shoot it depending upon how you're
shooting it if you're shooting it with a
bow and arrow you got to be real close
you got to be inside of 60 yards morning
hours badass I shot one with a bow and
arrow that one out there the big one I
shot with a rifle dude a bow and arrow
that's that's to me that's the [ __ ] I
saw Ted Nugent he shot a [ __ ] bear
you know which I could never do I
[ __ ] love bears it certain animals
but you know what I mean bears are
interesting I've shot bears you should
get you some bear sausage
I can't you bear I've shot three bears
with my Cantina back they're good and
delicious you like a [ __ ] sirloin
well we're not even a filet mignon you
gotta sleep tender and juicy I've always
felt that about you Jeff thank you we
think of bears I think very incorrectly
because with the you know with the word
anthropomorphize ation means when you
put a human characteristics and animals
like Yogi Bear and [ __ ] like that well
you make them ride a bicycle at the
circus we have this idea that bears
these cute things but where my friend
lives in Alberta where I hunt they
literally have to shoot them because
they don't have any predators so if
bears don't have any predators and they
just breed and they keep reading and
then they decimate the moose population
the elk population and they cannibalize
each other that's the thing that most
people they kind of handle it in-house
sort of but they eat babies that's what
they do most of the time I mean babies
they eat their own babies nakiya
sliders
black bear sliders oh why wouldn't you
well it's it's brutal to see you know
we've we've stumbled across pause and
stuff from cubs with a male boars no
that's what the ones that you see when
you just find a baby bear paw in the
woods I mean that a part of your soul
has to just [ __ ] it's got a dire cry
out like I bet something I never want to
see it's very strange I get I do have to
admit though that bear hunting is not I
don't like it as much as hunting other
animals if I had to choose like what
animals hunt you can't eat bear by the
way and that's the only things that I
hunt is what I eat black bear you can
eat grizzly bear but they don't taste
good most the reason for that because
grizzly bears mostly eat meat they eat a
few berries if you can find a grizzly
bear that was just eating berries
it would probably taste delicious they
literally taste like what they eat like
hunters try to go after bears that eat
berries like black bears in particular
in the fall they'll even blueberries
they call them blueberry bears because
like as you're opening them up their fat
is like a purple color and it tastes
like blueberries and apparently it's the
most delicious meat in the world so
without them realizing they're already
marinating themselves exactly you guys
leave show else Wow he's eating
themselves but my all-time favorite
animals are elk that's that's the best
they taste the best the best for you and
gave me that that elk me whatever the
last time I was on here and I made a
chili out of it and then the the [ __ ]
elk burgers it's a little dry somebody
gave me a hint to put a little bit of
butter in there to kind of you know yes
yeah you needed something like an agar
cell to make it stick together a little
bit you don't want it to cook it too
much because it's super lean yeah
no I put a piece of Swiss cheese or some
prosciutto on top ah [ __ ] insane you
good when you eat it too it's a powerful
food there's a lot of energy in those is
like there's there's so much nutrients
in elk it's like way more protein dense
way more nutrient dense yes they're kind
of like with the quick cuz they're wild
I know like the the human-like footprint
as I said you know acid rain and all the
[ __ ] horseshit we do but at least
it's it I would like to think it's kind
of away from the GMOs and all that it's
a you can get so GMOs do to you but like
the fresh [ __ ] tastes better though it
tastes better I mean GMOs everything's
that's a weird word like if you talk to
real scientists about GMOs most of time
when you talk about GMOs you're talking
to hippies and like you man you got to
stay away from GMOs you meant
genetically modified it's giving us
cancer it's terrible for the water but
real GMOs is almost everything we eat
every tomato you eat is genetically
modified
they've all in all throughout corn we
kind of what kind of like guinea pigs to
see like what what's gonna happen sort
of but most of it is just splicing like
I just found this out recently you know
that when you buy pistachios there's a
place up in Northern California with its
da she owes a statue of cheese nachos
spent only talking to Senator Reid long
thank you Stassi has Tasha and Joe
Rogan's anestachio
I like it with the team shelled of
course I don't Sheldon myself i buy
shelled pistachios I feel like I'm
cheating so just take big handfuls of
them and shoving my fat face you can't
do that there's a reason why there's a
shell on it because if you don't you can
eat a thousand of them yeah I buy them
in these big like two pound boxes and I
just pour my hands and I eat them
they're good good for you too
it's kind of guilt-free but you feel
like you're cheating like you'd have to
crack them I know why I stared you
off-course say you saw alienator when
they grow these pistachios the pistachio
trees the pistachio bushes are not a big
strong tree so they graft the limbs of
the pistachio tree onto like an avocado
tree a thicker stronger tree and they
grow pistachios on an avocado tree like
what it's like but you aren't we playing
God that we are playing God by driving
cars to fly in planes that [ __ ] is uh
like first of all I thought pistachios
came from the ground I thought peanuts
one in the ground peanuts
I think peanuts are in the ground is a
pistachio nut of the now wasn't it was a
Jimmy Carter was a peanut farmer how did
he do it should ask him I think it was
in the ground I don't I don't [ __ ]
know that's why I want to hunt
carrots are in the ground I just say are
Sophie worms are in the ground do you
grow it's not trying to recover it that
we don't know where the ground birds
from the sky dirt
do I know I mean my my the guy who cuts
the grass [ __ ] put him on so I got
Tomatoes I got lemons and limes but all
that did was just make me [ __ ] like
booze more because I'm just like it
totally got into Keith Aquila it's like
there's only so much guacamole you can
eat he just like what the [ __ ] else can
I do with this [ __ ]
so I kind of got into tequila it's less
of a hangover and dude up telling you
get all those big square ice cubes a
really nice sticky just like a patron
silver you put that in there and then
you go pick a [ __ ] lime off I'm
telling you it's why you it's why I live
out here it's not the showbiz it's the
booze well you don't really have to live
out here anymore right and especially
like your podcast the way you do your
podcasts you just rant like you could do
that [ __ ] thing and you do do it
anyway like but I also uh you know my
wife's in the business too so she does
acting she just he's doing a voiceover
today and so she doesn't have that
luxury and then also you know she would
go she would go crazy if if I if I you
know if I just moved to like the middle
of [ __ ] now I say it lived in the
middle of [ __ ] nowhere but I do when
I go in the road I always have that urge
like when I go to a place and I just
start thinking these guys riding around
motorcycles no helmets on yeah and it's
just like this
look at that Lake we got water here they
got they got they you know they got that
it's very lush land like living out here
is is it's terrifying it's terrifying
like what happened to the water in
Silver Lake
where did they take that they closed
silver like an actual Lake it Wow
my name is man-made but the water is all
gone now they're gonna develop it and
debt it they said they put it
underground didn't really say where it's
just it's just gone yeah do what I fly
that's one of the things I [ __ ] will
look down you go with Dodger Stadium and
then you start coming then you see
Silver Lake and then looking down like
where'd that parking lot what the big
top come from and the guy was like oh
that was silver laconic drain the water
I said they put it underground it's all
like vague
do you know when I was in I was in
Nashville this past weekend and I was
sitting there watching the news during
the day and they just go like um oh and
folks if you're in the downtown area and
you see the police doing something that
seems a little disturbing huh don't
worry it's just an exercise and then
they continued on and it was just like
you didn't do any follow up like or
there's no more information an exercise
what are they practicing for that
whatever they're doing is like scary now
I'm not saying they're gonna come at us
is it some sort of anti-terrorism thing
I have no [ __ ] idea what it was but
like just the the kind of vagueness that
they do now right before the Dodgers
score the other day NPR my wife listens
to that [ __ ] and I you know a McGee on
Morning Becomes eclectic if you enjoy
the show
fresh air with Terry Gross yeah now Joe
when you first started doing stand-up no
one I think of I've discussed this
before but it's kind of important you
know what I think of when I think of
those people you know that guy John
Ghomeshi is I like NPR but it's so
easily to be made fun of it's it's easy
to drive off the road into a [ __ ]
tree when you're listening to it - it's
oh yeah now there's a lot of droning on
but hawk which nobody does that really
super-sensitive left wing style of talk
the guy that was he do that really well
the main guy that did that was this guy
Jean Ghomeshi
who was on CBC in Canada and it turned
out he'd liked to beat the [ __ ] out of
girls when he was having sex with them
he would punched him in the face and
Club him in the head and it was crazy
[ __ ] and one girl I ain't mad yeah yeah
one and he would do it without ask you
know it was like you know like you know
that's a strong move it's wrong moving
the rack well I mean who knows the truth
because he was kind of acquitted of a
lot of it it was it's it's because it
was it was very difficult to find but
does he have the money to get acquitted
you know well that's true
that's a good point but he was fired and
there was a gang of girls and came out
and said he used to beat them up oh wait
wait wait wait the GAO does the
interview yes like this bill burr so
tell me do I heed you bugged me one time
when I'm not saying although I don't
know what the [ __ ] he does in his
personal life but Russell Peters was on
there and he just goes like he's like
Russell
you have nine cars and Russell's like
yeah and he goes why and it just [ __ ]
like making him feel bad because he's
doing well he's you know and then
Russell had to [ __ ] basically justify
didn't come up with money and now I can
have it I'm sorry I [ __ ] made it
Wow and I like cars Wow yeah now I'm not
saying it's one that's just saying it's
just right there well even it right
there that bugged me I hate when people
[ __ ] do stuff like he had to hit
somebody if you get like eight or nine
chicks they're saying you beat the [ __ ]
out of my house yeah what somebody got
cracked what is your number that
innocent until guilty or how many
accusations Bill Cosby I gave an around
thirty thirty we heard that right around
seven yeah no I I there was rumors of
his infidelity yes i I never heard of
ding you never heard that no I did I
heard that I had heard that it was like
a rumor it was a rumor that he would
drug women it was a rumor a long time
ago he was uh there was a report case
that is part of this case from I believe
it was like 2005 and that was one of the
reasons why they weren't allowed to
admit that evidence because the judge
had made a decision that if he paid this
woman off then it couldn't be admissible
in a future trial but it was all verbal
they didn't get anything on paper so
once they found out I didn't get this on
paper they're like well we're gonna
admit this and then the woman came out
and then he sued the woman that he gave
the money to for drugging her I know the
whole thing is very very sordid but with
Bill Cosby I think it's up to like 50 or
something crazy yeah so you gotta wonder
out of those 50 this is probably like 12
that are just crazy like you judge me
too ya know it's like the fact but the
fact that he'd still be open 30 it's
just nuts I think you know it was a you
know was one block when all that [ __ ]
came out about Trump right he did this
he did that blah blah blah it was all
pretty pedestrian sort of like oh he
grabbed my boob and then took me in the
back just just really generic sort of
lights become sort of the cliched story
and then this one woman saw sitting
there going like I'd the Clintons are
[ __ ] filthy
who knows if they paid these people who
knows what the [ __ ] going on it's
right before the list of when this is
coming out
and so I was going alright we'll see
we'll see and then this finally this
woman came on and she goes
so he made advancements at me and she
goes I just pushed him away and said get
real which is the perfect thing to say
cuz you're you're in your 20s he's like
[ __ ] 106 it's like yeah I'm serious so
she goes I said get real and then she
said he thrusts at his genitals towards
me and he said get real yeah she
imitated him I was in the car my wife we
say there's no [ __ ] way that it's
just too specific like I got the creeps
like get real so wonder what the
logistics are where the legality is
rather of the the audio tape like if you
don't know you're being recorded like
you know you're being recorded for a
show you're wearing a microphone but you
don't know you're being recorded while
you're on a bus and you're talking about
grabbing him by the [ __ ] and all that
Stevie's talking to me I can track she's
talking [ __ ]
yeah like Joey Diaz would say something
like that and I would be [ __ ] crying
laughing and he would be egging it up he
would ramp it up he would make it way
exaggerated because he knows it's funny
he's going for the lab you're sitting
next to Trump and he's like I just
grabbed by the [ __ ] you'd be [ __ ]
crying laughing that's why it was Julia
Bush I defended him on my podcast like
it like I'm not saying that guys a great
guy but a fire a [ __ ] guy because of
a [ __ ] 20 second clip from 11 years
ago what's he supposed to do he's
interviewing the guy and what you're
supposed to do is keep the interview
what happened yes the interviewee happy
so exact grand by the [ __ ] yeah he
doesn't even say anything bad Billy Bush
didn't say anything bad it just got shot
this guy at work said well when he said
to the woman go over and give him a hug
he became part of the sexual assault and
I was just like what sect there was no
sexual assault what they were saying if
he actually did it was but the whole
thing was just like okay it's just you
know I understand what I'm getting
flipping out about it as far as
obviously just the whole it would be
them but yes what they don't know is the
way guys talk when they're not there
yeah and I'm just gonna sit through the
[ __ ] [ __ ] that we've said and we say
it for fun you don't say because we
really
go grab someone by the [ __ ] and pick
him up like a bowling ball yeah and say
it because it's funny it's funny and you
just you're tied completely ridiculous
it inappropriate yes yeah say if you do
have a billion dollars I what I'm
learning through Cosby and all these
[ __ ] guys is evidently you can do
that and it did say that he's going like
you get famous enough you can just walk
up and buy the [ __ ] object that was
just so absurd to me I'm like you can do
that you can't do that well he's got so
much money you gotta think when you get
off that guy and get you six grand in
cash if he just don't correct
I think he's leveraged out totally but
I'm pretty sure you go to the ATM and
get six rent but I know you're
exaggerating to six grands a funny
number
it's a funny number it is funny right
I'm just saying right dude is like
liquid rich right and your assets are
paid off and then there's oh I got this
I'm gonna take a loan against this and
then I'm gonna do that get some
investors here and then I'm going to
stick my [ __ ] name on it to build my
brand there's that way where you're sort
of like steroid and up your value but at
the end of the day it's like all right
but what how much can you get me right
[ __ ] now like I don't get that whole
like well all my shits tied up right and
I got other guys you know I'm working
with let me see the zeroes what's in
your bank account show me yes yes that
helicopter that helicopter with your
name on the back is that paid off is
that a sticker but is that a sticker
that they take off and then they put
[ __ ] Mark Cuban on the back there's
no woman showing up at his house and
you're having you're supposed to have a
business lunch you don't know that you
you show up he's got this sprawling
estate that looks like a castle he's got
these enormous grounds he's probably got
50 people working just at his house
there's be my greeting you they're
taking you into these rooms he comes out
in a $10,000 suit he's got diamonds and
Rolexes and everything's beautiful
you're like holy [ __ ] Donald Trump his
toupee is like 80 grand why is he gonna
weigh you and I did you and I recognized
it was over because I don't think it was
acceptable back then but it's except
Jordan had to make it acceptable Jordan
made it except you may accept a full
black eyes curly Neal of the
Globetrotters it's not acceptable for
black guys then Jordan will
just you know everyone wanted to be like
Mike and then I haven't when he was at
the height that was black guys young
with the full heads and [ __ ] hair
would shave their head just to look like
him that's [ __ ] insane he'll do that
well what about Yul Brenner and Yul
Brynner was the first white guy to rock
it and be a movie star
oh yeah The King and I West world the
original West world that's the HBO
series you know I tried to buy the
rights to that like [ __ ] ten years
ago you did yeah yeah I don't know what
I was gonna buy was just like this is a
movie that someone's gonna want to redo
because they're redoing all these movies
from my childhood and I was just like I
[ __ ] love that movie that thing
really loans itself cuz we're not at the
point where you can do any of the [ __ ]
so it's still in the future you could
totally but that but they wanted like a
zillion dollars for I didn't really
michael crichton book and all that they
wanted like millions and millions and I
was just like all right like [ __ ] 30
grand like a Prius have you watched the
show well this is the thing then the
second I sat down and I watched the show
I just watched the opening credits and I
was like oh thank god thank God I didn't
have the rights to that because there's
no [ __ ] way I could have pulled that
off like all the things like the horse
running yeah and those tendons
connecting I've watched the first two
episodes I'm totally in and I've already
bugged my agent to be like dude I will
[ __ ] the same way when I saw Breaking
Bad I just like I watched the first two
episodes and I was like dude I will
carry a tray of meth in the background
whatever you can [ __ ] do so I bugged
him going like I'm actually bullshitting
that's all my agenda today I'm gonna
want to get out of this I'm done here
and I walk home with my elk meat
hopefully I got pounds for I'm gonna I'm
gonna I'm gonna bug him about trying
trying to get on that thing and there's
actually there's a couple of actors in
there that I've worked with that I'm
just psyched that they're on so you know
you see you see friends of yours that
are actually in there and they're on
something that you have been cool and
friend Tate my friend Tate was on last
week's episode yes world he's on
everything no Tate's Tate's been in I
don't know 100 movies probably easily a
hundred movies
I've always wondered if you know when
you you're doing something great cuz
it's so hard when you're shooting it and
how they just all right now his point of
view would do the master back back back
and do it all that type of stuff and you
just find yourself walking around was it
good did it you know it's the camera
crew who's not saying anything
everybody's [ __ ] quiet
it's uh it really comes down though to
the editors and the music and they can
either take it to the next level or they
can relay can make something good look
great and they can take something great
look [ __ ] horrific well something
start off great then they don't end it
and they [ __ ] it up
but there's something weird about having
a friend in a movie where you going this
movie's great
oh there's tape like it takes you out of
it it's like oh that's my friend like
this movie's [ __ ] yeah people I say
it doesn't it doesn't it doesn't take me
it doesn't take me out of it unless I
see them like watching themselves like I
can't believe I'm in this scene with
this guy then it then it like pulls me
out but like I i'd buy in when i'm one
of those guys like i don't like going to
horror movies like they freak me out i
buy in i don't give a [ __ ] what the
concept is like that [ __ ] thing where
the lady was like flipping the light
switch off and then turning it on and
then flipped it off and saw the thing
again and then turned it on and then
flipped off it was right there
i was literally at home my stop [ __ ]
I don't know like that movie was coming
out and was like the thing where she's
like she's like you know you look into a
room and you shut the lights I shuts
lights off and all of a sudden there's
this [ __ ] thing there sort of a girl
sort of [ __ ] beastly and it's across
the room so you can't quite see it's
just like what the [ __ ] is that turns
the lights on it's gone shuts it off
it's there again same spot turns the
lights back on it's not there shuts it
off the third time and it's right in a
[ __ ] grill mmm yeah scared the [ __ ]
out of me Blair Witch Blair which one
they wouldn't give me a Ralphie may go
didn't [ __ ] scare me him that movie
the [ __ ] out of me I saw that movie by
myself I'd done a spot at the Laugh
Factory
I went down to the Mann's Chinese
Theater though the one that Hollywood
galaxy I don't know that's still there
anymore right next door and I saw like
the midnight showing by myself dude
freaked those theatres yeah but nobody I
knew and it was like really sort of like
there wasn't a lot of people there and
then that walked through the parking
garage
oh dude I was [ __ ] I was freaked I
saw that movie in Houston Texas Chris
McGowan and I did a show we did a show
at the old laugh stop you ever do the
old laugh stop folks did I do that one
great club I think I just whatever the
classic one was that Hicks and all those
guys it had just moved
News 5 spot sucked the new spot was not
good but the old spot was amazing and
that's where I did my first album mmm
that was I'm gonna be dead someday I did
in 1999 mm-hmm
we we did a show and then McGwire and I
met these kids that worked across the
street at the movie theater and they go
hey do you guys we have the keys to the
movie theater you guys want to go watch
the Blair Witch just us we're like holy
[ __ ] let's do it so we left we had a
10:00 o'clock show it's like midnight we
go across the street they [ __ ] cook
up the popcorn the whole deal gave us
free salsa
lock the door you could even do that
today no no it was amazing I mean today
everything's digital you know the kid
spools up the [ __ ] the reel and
everything like that and we sat down in
a theater it was like three of them and
two of us and we watched the Blair Witch
and [ __ ] our pants it was awesome oh my
god Josh screaming I still remember that
when the kids staring in the corner oh
yeah when they just sort of like went
past it yeah all of that [ __ ] were
rather than just showing you saw in
somebody's head off just the idea yeah
when you think of like Tarantino talked
about that were in Reservoir Dogs
he had one scene where they showed the
guy hack in the ear off versus just
panning away and hearing the guy scream
and it's just like it was way more
[ __ ] disturbing that that ruined that
song for me for a long time I always
know what song was that Marvin Nash
screaming now here Stephen Wright's
voice well I don't know we film oh yeah
yeah that was that's something today
yeah right adding a fun song to a
horrific scene oh that was so the
powerlessness of just [ __ ] I can't I
can't I can't deal with that's like
Scarface
remember Scarface when they cut the guy
up with the chainsaw he's tied up in the
in the bathtub and they forced Tony
Montana watch he's getting splattered
with blood as they hack his friend up ya
know my mother took us to see that she
didn't know what it was
took all of us to see it and my youngest
brother was like nine I think
my mother said after this chainsaw scene
we have to get out of here I would have
been like fine cuz I'm gonna watch then
I go that goes really I asked my mother
years later she was just like well yeah
I thought at that point yes that it
might have been a little mature mature
for your youngest brother and but I was
laughing I was going yeah but you always
took us to cool movie she goes and she
goes yeah she goes that was a good move
she goes I'm gonna take care of those
stupid key things like she was against
like the whole she took us to full of of
Benjy and Herbie goes to Monte Carlo and
then my parents were just like we're not
[ __ ] sitting through this [ __ ] we're
gonna go to a movie that we're going to
enjoy too and then I went from that to
like stripes we're gonna go out we're
gonna go there yeah we're gonna see
something but let me I'm sweating like a
pig you turn eighteen oh yeah let's uh
let's get to UM let's get to what I
wanted to promote here you got your
stand-up special triggered coming out so
first I'll sorry alright when is it uh
when is it airing I don't see any my
saying where did you shoot it this is my
bad as an interviewer how bad I'm trying
to think of what I'm supposed to ask you
San Francisco to Fillmore yeah I wanted
to do it at a comedy club and there was
like a debate between Netflix and me
Netflix wanted to do it at a huge place
I wanted to do it at a tiny place cuz I
did my last one at The Comedy Works in
Denver which is only like a couple
hundred people and I like that I think
there's something about when you're
sitting in a living room and you're
sitting on the couch you watched a
comedy special it lends itself better to
being in a like a club when you're
filming it it feels more intimate you
know I see like you're on top of the
crowd it's more like what it would be
like the environment that it would be
mm-hmm
so we made a compromise we did the film
or theater which is a [ __ ] really
cool theater and it's only 450 seats
it's pretty small it's got a high
ceiling and it's kind of a big stage and
everything that but it's a fairly small
place but that's cool but next one I'm
gonna do in a small place I think I
think I might do it the store yes funny
is when I went to go do mine at the
Tabernacle you had already been there
and did one so I was like how am I gonna
make this different and I did the film
or in 2009 let it go I did there did you
yeah
gone back in wait are you doing your new
one yeah I did it last Friday you did it
yep I did it at the Ryman in Nashville
dude I was just there
I [ __ ] love that play place is crazy
they used to do the Grand Ole Opry yes
Cedric the Entertainer just did one
there so I watched like the opening to
his just to see because I was like
because then you got to kind of disguise
it so it doesn't look like oh my god
he's at the exact same [ __ ] place in
his house you know it guy's huge so I
wanted to make sure I was like all right
well we gotta try to you know he came in
with a whole marching band and all that
which is the exact opposite to my style
so I was like okay cool
Katt Williams brought a lion he brought
a lion onstage funniest guys alive and
you know in its walls to go on stage
with a [ __ ] lion is hilarious how do
you come I won I wish I was in that
[ __ ] pitch meeting what's the concept
I'm coming on stage with a lion a lion
in a cage like a stuff for now real one
he got so sweaty during his special he
had to stop and change clothes is that
right yeah you literally stop I'll be
right back drenched I mean it's
completely smooth what is if they point
they put that HD makeup on and then
there's all those lights on you yeah and
then then you're going hard yeah cuz
it's your special and you really want to
make sure you're gonna get a good one
and then if the [ __ ] AC is a little
messed up yeah if the crowds all [ __ ]
packed in in the wrong venue yeah you
can get yourself into a situation I
don't wear makeup on those things I
wouldn't wear it for Comedy Central I
don't wear it for the UFC
I don't wear for anything just like I
don't what I look like yeah I think it's
good it came first of all from fear
factor when I first start doing Fear
Factor they wanted they put like a
little anti shine on me a little of this
and a little that and after a while I'm
like look these [ __ ] people are
covered in blood I mean they've got dirt
all over their face and I'm sitting
there with makeup on you have to touch
me up in between scenes you know
ridiculous that is yes and then we would
go from that to the UFC where people
were literally their faces are getting
busted open their get
giant [ __ ] I never noticed like when
I watched you on the UFC I never noticed
like oh wow like he can he want a TV
without makeup that's so brave that's
such a courageous thing I you just you
look like you well that's what I look
like you know I'm just like I'm not you
know Mike Goldberg gets it they spray it
on there's like an airbrush I'm not
kidding there's an airbrush they do it
to everybody all the ring girls and
everything the airbrush them that's what
they go that far I put it through my
giant forehead I gotta get sunshine how
dude I got you beat the same weight
classes we're gonna crazy on stage I
sweat like crazy I mean my last special
I looked at it when I was doing the
editing I'm like Jesus I'm sweaty [ __ ]
like it just looks ridiculous looks like
I'm like I'm on drugs
yeah but you're up there working and
you're not like just standing there so
yeah this one I I didn't have any this
last night
I made sure the a/c was cranked like
with each special I learned something
yeah so I was like make sure the eight
you know the ACS cranked don't [ __ ]
cake the makeup on or whatever just so
it was just a little bit of that that's
that's that's all those stupid little
[ __ ] things you know don't stick my
parents in the front row please just
beyond beyond the pale yeah and I I
don't show any audience anymore I
decided no more audience I never did
yeah that's the way to go no audience
shots and everything kind of mostly from
the waist up unless you need to see my
legs for like a particular thing I'm
doing yeah secrets because of it because
now I feel like because there's so many
specials coming out so many [ __ ]
specials coming out that you know that
then it becomes like you you have to
have like whatever you'll look is you
know what I mean I mean to think about
is you have such a great act that's
gonna stand on anyways but if you can
add like your own sort of style the way
you shoot them that becomes part of your
thing that's another way to try to get
it out cuz you get on Netflix with the
specials dude you just yeah you [ __ ]
scroll and scroll and scroll and
scrolling I guess so I just wanted it to
be like you're watching it like no
cutaways
I don't want cutting to the laughs
cutting to the right cutting for no
reason like like there was a director
that I work with once it was like you
know we'd have to cut to the
you know that's all we're gonna do our
edits I go let's just try to do with no
edits we can't of course we can if I do
a good show we could do with no edits
he's like no look trust me we're gonna
do this I'm like no this is my [ __ ]
special I don't even know you
yeah like you're coming in here and you
wanted to do all this stupid [ __ ] and
and film the crowd and you know the
people want to know that people are
laughing I'm like they're gonna hear
them laughing like it takes you in my
opinion it takes you out of it Bill
Cosby himself oh yeah perfectly sits
down for like an hour and 40 minutes
killing they never they never go to the
crowd the background just slowly changes
different colors and guy absolutely
murdered you and I were supposed to go
see Bill Cosby in Vegas we had made like
we were talking about doing it but we
both flaked and we never wound up doing
it and that's one of my main regrets
this day I would have liked to see him
before the stink hit him I did I saw it
right before I met him and then three
months later I saw him remember when he
was doing shows still like all those
women were coming out he was still doing
shows like he was still doing shows he
was like [ __ ] it I'm still doing them
and he went out and he still did though
Schultz for a little while I think I
think he thought he was powerful enough
to just sort of ignore it and then it
wasn't gonna it wasn't gonna come around
but dude I got to tell you if you gave
me a thousand guests not a thousand but
if you gave me two hundred guesses his
name would not be on that'll out of all
the [ __ ] of all the [ __ ] people like
if you said okay this there's a comic
out there doing this [ __ ] really you got
your top 20 will you'd be like oh yeah
you know what I never heard the rumors I
did hear the rumors and also there was a
time am I not in the clubhouse how am i
a comedian this long and I'm not [ __ ]
here in the rumors I heard it from
Hollywood people I didn't hear it from
comics I heard people in the business I
heard it from like actors and from
people that like work on TV show sets I
heard it during the news radio days I
had heard it yeah oh he's doing it at
the show he was doing it to people that
were on the show too to people allegedly
who the [ __ ] knows but there's something
with it was something unbelievable
unbelievably creepy but after the
accusations came out when he was still
doing shows he would go on stage with
one eye looking to the left one eye
looking straight he developed a dead eye
somewhere along the line right
so go on stage with that weird kind of
some slack he's like 90
I know i'ma for the grace of God but
he's dying right that's my point is like
things are falling off the wheels right
the wheels are falling off the ride and
he's got this shirt on
this sweater on it says hello friend and
he's he's onstage and he walks out there
and everybody's clapping and cheering
and some guys yeah you're right best you
are a rapist and then you know they grab
the guy and shuffle him out and then
people going we love you bill and he
just doesn't even acknowledge that just
ignore them just ignore them
yeah it was something crazy about that
it was like the last the last sparks
before they threw the water on the fires
like there was just a little hope like a
gas you got some embers blast spark
before they to the gas remain I mean his
career I mean Eva's life they threw
water on him like I mean he's just it's
over like no one's gonna go see him live
now right I mean it's kind of over I'm
doesn't water put out the sparks yes
that's what I mean it through the water
on him they say yeah no I mean like he
had a moment of like there was still
some sparks okay the accusations came
out but he was still doing these shows
and people still came out I'm not I'm
not the brightest it wasn't a good
analogy I was your analogies probably
better you know the blowing the flames
on the fire it's like we almost had it
out like it was almost who do you know
my last flight sort of caught on fire
what helicopter flight no no no airplane
jet yeah flying back from my special
Nashville to LA and we got up to
cruising altitude it smelled like burnt
popcorn so I was like did the stewardess
is like well fast forward through this
was it-- already told him I think about
was like did they burn the [ __ ] meal
or something and then it sort of went
away then it kind of came back and I
felt us with everybody had the shades
pulled down I felt like we were starting
to descend and then it felt really like
I felt like the wing shaken and [ __ ] and
I was like oh wow man like there must be
some turbulence I thought it was just
descending to go underneath it and then
go back up again you like it get a
little bit smoother air here sorry about
the bully ride if I was gonna be doing
that [ __ ] never said a [ __ ] word and
then all of a sudden like Mike drink
that was in the late little middle
armrest started
sliding forward like it was gonna fall
to the floor and I'm like I'll [ __ ] and
then the stewardess came home she goes
yeah we're gonna be landing here shortly
so I have to take those drinks right and
then the woman next to me she landed
premature oh yeah we've only 50 minutes
into the flight from Nashville to LA my
favorite thing was a woman next to me
takes her headphones up she say are we
here already we just [ __ ] tell me
you're on the Concorde I was like no I
was on fire I don't know I don't know
what it was I was thinking like I'll
[ __ ] it's it's gonna be something in
somebody's bag like the luggage is [ __ ]
some [ __ ] like that valujet something
caught on fire underneath there and like
my whole thing was when we were going
down I wasn't nervous because he had
full control of the plane maneuvering it
and all that and I just knew like yeah
if you smell smoke that is a the
procedure is land immediately so that's
what he's doing and we're 30,000 feet up
so he's gonna land quickly that's the
shaking that's fine I feel it's making
turns and banks everything's working but
my whole thing is you know I don't know
anything about planes but I'm just like
if it burns through the wrong wire if
the hydraulics like what the [ __ ]
gonna happen so yeah we came into a
landing in Little Rock and and we came
in like over this river and I couldn't
see the runway oh you can't see straight
so I'm just looking out the sign I just
see this [ __ ] river I'm seem to be
following it that's not thinking like is
he gonna Sully this thing and [ __ ]
send us into the water and I was already
thinking in you know what's gonna happen
the front part of the plane is gonna get
[ __ ] up so that doors not gonna open
some of it [ __ ] fight past these
first-class people into coach you know
what I mean we're real people work so
they're gonna be solid thinking about
muscle me as they get through this I'm
gonna be [ __ ] if we use the
first-class door I can take out the
chick next to me and find people gonna
be unconscious anyway just from the
stress and the impact do you know was uh
was hilarious was the the woman across
the alpha me was totally freaking out
because unfortunately her dad I guess
had died in a plane crash
so she was totally like like totally
[ __ ] hyperventilating to the point was
making me angry it's like how [ __ ]
freaked out she was what kills me is
she's told she's totally freaking out
about that but I swear to god dude like
ten minutes earlier barefoot walked in
used the bathroom and came back out that
like that doesn't scare her that doesn't
scare her but a [ __ ] a couple of
lights on in the cockpit you know and
the smell of burnt popcorn now she's
freaking out
what the [ __ ] they're put in the
bathroom is is a new thing I've been
flying for 20 years I've never seen it
it started it with socks and now it's
socks are even [ __ ] worse he's like
you absorb it but whatever happened to
women were they decided to wear shoes
that hurt like what if they always have
but what the [ __ ] is that about that is
because of their lack of power they
couldn't get a good job you know I
mayn't believe me if it was switched the
other way if you made a doll less than
our eye you couldn't imagine the shoes
you'd be wearing right now Joe that's
enough do you know that that's not true
do you know that that whole thing about
the the the gender disparity the wage
gap is not true do you know what that
actually is it's choices and jobs it's
not job for job like if you were an
engineer and you working next to a woman
she wouldn't be making 70 cents to your
dollar it's [ __ ] it's a lie and it's
one of those propaganda things that they
like to tout and you heard [ __ ] Obama
talk about it Sarah Silverman talked
about it when she was trying to get
Hillary Clinton elected it's a it's a
weird thing that people keep her but she
was not Bernie Sanders I thought Sarah
Silverman was with Hillary Clinton I
thought it was initially Bernie Sanders
then ever maybe she was then everybody
jump ship and one [ __ ] Hillary
include Bernie who then [ __ ] endorsed
Hillary and it's like there's your
credit money right it might be burned if
she was endorsing but it's that thing
that they say that's just not true what
it is it's two factors one there's a lot
this the less hours women tend to work
less hours they also tend to take risk
guns they're less easy
well just joking just leave this
maternity leaves as a bunch of their
factors they're less crazy less
ambitious they don't have as much
testosterone obviously they're not it's
[ __ ] crazy man every willing to work
themselves into the grave and when
they're working side by side doing the
same job there's almost no disparity at
all there's a few jobs where men get
paid more than women but it's not much
and it's certainly not 70 cents to the
dollar and this is one thing that gets
touted out over and over again by people
but it's just not true I didn't know I
did look I had a friend of mine who I
got an argument about it was talking
about divorce where we were talking
about a buddy of ours that got [ __ ] in
a divorce and he goes hey maybe it's to
make up for the fact that women only
make 70 cents an hour ago okay the fact
that you say that drives me [ __ ]
crazy because you think it's a good
point don't ya and he goes yeah I go do
you ever research that he goes no but
it's a fact I go it's not a fact it's
not a fact
they make 70 cents compared yes a guy
said this he's a guy he likes to argue
he's a friend of mine who likes to argue
hey you just got it yeah you gotta walk
away from that now he's a good guy he's
a good guy but he's got a [ __ ]
problem he doesn't like when he doesn't
know something and what he doesn't know
something he doesn't go holy [ __ ] really
he goes that's not true what the [ __ ]
it's true it's [ __ ] true like go
google it [ __ ] web series I want to
watch you guys drive from here to San
Francisco just watching you losing your
[ __ ] it's [ __ ] true what couple times
we've gotten in these arguments we've
gotten in like three of them it's like I
when I'm not when I don't know something
I'll say I don't know or if someone says
something and I didn't know that I'll go
holy [ __ ] is that true he's the opposite
he's like that's not true so if I don't
know something I'll do a bit on it twice
twice this [ __ ] guy's done this like
I know what I'm talking about
but I get a bit on the wage gap of my
new well there you go
my old thing was like how the [ __ ] did
they find out what everybody makes you
just call up the IRS can we get that you
too is on everybody
they gotta give me that information well
I don't know I don't know I know I did
but all I know that's what it is harder
for them straight across the board that
is the Fremen just everything is harder
and all of our lives are easier that's
the [ __ ] message you say you're being
sarcastic I am NOT just like I you have
one of my favorite jokes of all time
about motherhood being what the harsh
out of the world he goes House is the
hardest job in the world when you
wearing [ __ ] pajamas all day no job
you can do in your pajamas I'm not
saying it's not [ __ ] no but it's fun
[ __ ] yeah it's obviously difficult but
it's a funny prank still hoping ya go
work on an oil rig that [ __ ] blows up
exactly and as you jump into the [ __ ]
like on fire water going underneath that
and then you're just sitting there with
second-degree burns and salt [ __ ]
water hoping that Coast Guard gets there
before the shark eats you alive talk to
me about you talk to me about the
terrible twos I have a friend of mine
who works at a oil rig in Canada in
northern Alberta work it's 50 below zero
and I go how do you do it do they work
outside I go ahead
as well you keep the truck running and
you work for about seven to ten minutes
at a time and you have to go inside the
truck for about a half an hour I go
really
he goes yeah he goes you can't take any
more because you any exposed skin you
have he does you try to cover your face
up as much as possible you put a ski
mask on but just your eyes just all
around your eyes is all [ __ ] up like
everything's [ __ ] up it's like it's
just too cold you just can't do it 50
below zero they just work for short
stretches of time then they go in the
car and then the other guy will go out
while he's in there and then he'll go
out for like ten minutes
and then they take a break for another
10-15 minutes and they're like the first
guy will go back out yeah all of those
shows make me so thankful that I'm a
comedian those [ __ ] crab is the
[ __ ] worst job you had as far as
physically like like I will kill myself
before I'm 30 if I [ __ ] do this out
of high school I worked on a there was a
Knights of Columbus Hall that was having
a wheelchair ramp built and I had to
carry cement bags and pressure-treated
lumber every day and I only lasted a
little over two weeks I think I lasted
eight days I was a gofer on a
construction site we were we were
roofing in June or July oh and I just
remember having to bring up those first
of all I brought the wrong I bought the
wrong color [ __ ] shingles they wanted
the [ __ ] evany one and this was off
mm what the [ __ ] it was so I had to go
all the way back
unload the [ __ ] things I load it on
load some more back brought the [ __ ]
things back and I just remember dude it
was just like I never ate so much in my
life like I'd eat like three sandwiches
and like a half hour later I'd be like
starving and yeah weight was just
falling off of me I was just like dude
what the [ __ ] this is insane and but the
thing was if I hung in there for like a
month I would have got my sea legs but I
I just was like no but I didn't have it
I knew it I always knew I always knew
like when I play drums and everything
like that as much every time I thought I
was getting good I go into Guitar Center
and some eight-year-old kid would get on
a kid and I'd be like holy [ __ ] like
that's like dude I would pay you to give
me lessons it's just like that when you
switched when whatever you're trying to
do when you see like a kid come in and
he [ __ ] blow I mean blows you away
it's just like it's just like III this
is this is a
people this is a hobby well he's an
American doing construction is
definitely not a [ __ ] hobby it's just
brutal but is it gay labor they think
it's there's a gift as far as like
seeing how things go together yeah
there's an art to everything suitcase of
[ __ ] contractors guys no I mean as
far as building houses but I mean
laboring like carrying bags of cement
there's no [ __ ] art to carrying bags
of cement but no but they would give me
[ __ ] to do like you know make this
[ __ ] miter cut for you and I I [ __ ]
the same cut up three times in a row it
was to frame a door jamb and I kept
measuring to the inside of the corner
rather the outside of the corner
remember it's third time I did it that
my boss just looked at me grabbed the
wood and he looked at me the whole time
walked up to the frame and never never
took his eyes off me the frame was
behind him and he just stuck it to the
[ __ ] wall and just stared at me I was
so embarrassed I was just like god dude
he's like dude you're going you went
through like [ __ ] twenty dollars
worth this stock to make one one [ __ ]
cut like what are you doing here I was
just like I was I don't even like the
show I didn't pick up my check I drove
up to the site I work Monday through
Friday and then Monday Tuesday Wednesday
I drove up to the site and I just looked
at it and my body everything just said
dude [ __ ] this and I just kept driving
he never called why would he call me I'm
like a waste in lumber he doesn't give a
[ __ ] he got free labor out of me and I
didn't give a [ __ ] and I forget what
what I did after that but that was a
rough time for me but like I always knew
like if I'd if I didn't like a job and
stuff like desi it's like the De Niro
thing and was that the heat you got to
be willing to walk in any moment you got
to be rolling to [ __ ] walk you got to
know it's bad yeah yeah what was it that
was the probably the toughest physical
job that I had and it was also but good
it was a good lesson because it was a
lesson that like if you work for
somebody else and you're just doing
labor you're just doing just mindless
labor you don't have any time for
anything else you think you got eight
hours in a day and there's still another
16 you'll get [ __ ] done you're exhausted
you're [ __ ] beaten down I would go to
the gym I try to workout and I remember
trying to hit the bag and I just had
nothing there was nothing that I'd never
felt so tired of my life yeah I was only
like 18 I should have been full of piss
and vinegar odds I was just dead and I'm
like all my ambition wheels would just
ramp it up I was like okay this is not
my [ __ ] future I got to figure out
what the [ __ ] I'm doing said I had these
delusions that I was gonna become a
carpenter I was like wow get in the
Union I'll start building houses that's
a good gig which it is you know if
you're that's what I thought I was gonna
do yeah you know what it's a good gig if
you're the guy telling the people to go
build the [ __ ] house but if you're
the guy out there pour in the forms
you've noticed that that's mostly young
guys like that is a [ __ ] young even
like landscaping like after a while you
got to get a crew and you got to be the
guide like sending the crews out because
there's only so long that you can just
like I feel like like laborers and that
they have like the same career
trajectory as like a professional
athlete somewhere around 35 to 38 your
body's gonna be like dude I can't I
can't I can't [ __ ] do this anymore
you just break down there was a I had a
bulging disc in my neck and I went to an
MRI place and there was a lady who went
in before me lady lady and this lady I
was looking at different people's MRIs
and this lady had the most [ __ ]
ridiculous cartoon bulge of her disk
some poor woman who I think she worked
in a laundromat or something like that
just carrying baskets of clothes and her
back was she's so [ __ ] up and she was
probably like 40 years old or something
like that came over here from you know
Mexico or Guatemala or something and I
remember looking at her back like in it
like this poor lady has no choice she
has to go to work there's no way around
this and there's no jobs for her other
than this you know like what she she
can't speak English she's got to do what
the [ __ ] she's got to do and she had you
went into our chart huh he started
reading right there it was just sitting
up there on the screen
and I asked the guy whose back is had he
goes it's hers I holy [ __ ] it was mine
like that battles no he was that's bad
he goes that's bad it's real bad like
she could barely walk like she had
sciatica up and down her leg oh I had
that yeah well that's what that like
what sciatica is a bulging disc
it's a disc that's pressing against the
nerves you had it what you do about it I
went to masseuse that helped oh yeah she
actually she works on she's a magician
dude she started with like I came real
who's she start with but went how it
came through me was through my drum
teacher so it was like MMA people oh
okay
and then you know the whole some drummer
or guitarist or something was into MMA
[ __ ] up something and he say go to my
masseuse and then she got all the
musicians with like that with a
tendinitis and all that [ __ ] in the
forearms and then it came around to me
through my drum teacher and she was like
mate like my left side was [ __ ] up
like the left leg and she started with
my right shoulder cuz your right
shoulders compensating for your left
side yeah so she was doing the whole
ride let's try to get some information
you know see what's going on here and
then she'd do something I just go like
okay and then scale of 1 to 10 the
painted dude like she what she did for
me like literally she went so [ __ ]
deep it was like these memories come out
I mean my brother used to just give me
charley horses and [ __ ] for no [ __ ]
reason he remembered it yeah it was a
store no not like the pain of it like
you just pops up I just I wouldn't be
like literally thinking and you just
have the thought like yeah my brother
used always kicked me in the [ __ ] leg
there and there was another one I
remember I was playing pick-up hockey
and I had no stuff all I had was the
[ __ ] the the helmet and the gloves in
the skate had like sweatpants and like a
[ __ ] t-shirt or whatever and I'm out
there like an [ __ ]
and I've you know going down the ice and
all of a sudden the other team gets it
so I pop over to [ __ ] start skating
backwards I caught an edge and just went
up in the air and just landed on my left
ass cheek and [ __ ] dude I landed so
[ __ ] hard like I couldn't breathe and
my eyes were watering it's like
literally pee when you're skating it's
like being thrown out of a moving car
right so I got up and everyone was laugh
and I [ __ ] up my elbow you know it's
hockey see just fine you know I get to
the bench and I was fine and a couple
shifts later it kind of worked itself
out and I had bruised my legs so bad it
was like three days later I was on the
road and I was showering or something I
just saw on the side of my leg it looked
like I had sat in grease or something
and I that I looked all the way the back
of my leg it looked like someone took a
pipe and just had [ __ ] whacked me as
hard as you could across
the back of my leg is straight [ __ ]
line and I think my sciatic nerve thing
was which is a culmination of all of
that [ __ ] and then there was that last
thing that did it so she [ __ ] worked
all the way out of that she gave me all
these stretches and then I found like a
good chiropractor and all that and it's
all good now yeah I'll do it I couldn't
show you a [ __ ] I couldn't even sit down
because of my feet were stuck would
start to tingle and stuff what numbness
is way worse than that's beyond pain is
what I heard stuff the numbness thing is
worse so she goes all right we're gonna
work you from numbness down to pain and
then pain hopefully down to that and I
just I just started going every [ __ ]
week but I got a machine I have to show
you it's called a reverse hyper and some
machine that decompresses your back
while strengthening it it's you lift
weights with it you lift your legs up
and then it strengthens your back and
then as you live I know this [ __ ] well I
work for the Ultimate Fighting
Championship
I mean I've been in [ __ ] for every time
I get this [ __ ] chamber right
attention to stuff I mean that's what I
do I have been intention to the wrong
[ __ ] I've been doing martial arts since
I was a little kid I mean maintaining
your body's a big part of that it's one
of the most difficult parts of martial
arts is not getting injured all the time
your Khan because martial arts are all
about hurting people so that's
practicing hurting each other so like
you have to find good partners there's
always that guy in class that was too
[ __ ] hard there's always that that's
Charlie Murphy talking about that guy
yeah it's a big problem Charlie sent me
and I only lasted a couple weeks of the
dojo my [ __ ] ad deal I maybe I
learned how to cook now if you know I
just left butch I was just like ah
here's the deal you're gonna go down
there when was this that we do in the
rich [ __ ] tour really yeah he was you
were doing much what kind of martial
arts renown whatever style he has his
[ __ ] blood to it I only I only lasted
like two weeks
I [ __ ] I actually took jujitsu with
Dom fig did you real in the late 90s I
lasted like five weeks of doing that
actually did I write I did all right but
then the guy teaching he couldn't speak
English and this lady like dislocated
like her [ __ ] rib cage can something
[ __ ] up happen and he didn't know what
to do and I just remembered like you
know
home with bruises and [ __ ] it was like
that was like when Pilate sees you could
actually get on something and I was just
like [ __ ] am i doing why don't I make
enough money where I have security
actually get on something yeah finally
remember development deals yeah and [ __ ]
could actually happened and you go to
Montreal and get a deal and then you be
set
I just member the guy skip the heap it's
like this huh no good it's like this ah
it's good that was the whole [ __ ]
class like easier like these no like
this escape it this game yeah yeah
Skippy heap whatever the [ __ ] he was
saying and you know I learned some [ __ ]
I still know if I'm on my back how to
get somebody into an armbar but it's
probably well it's probably I look at
martial arts it's like comedy so like I
think that that worked in the late 90s
but now that would be like a corny joke
now and I think like that move back dude
I'm gonna [ __ ] try that like an 8
year old knows how to get out of it like
you're funny at the office you think
you're gonna go kill at the Ryman
Auditorium it's more like a time thing
we're like that was probably
state-of-the-art [ __ ]
whatever we state of the art then I mean
you talk to drama god I was like 18
years ago there's no [ __ ] way that
move everybody knows that moves it's
like playing drums well actually all the
standard old-school moves of Brazilian
Jujitsu are still good they're all still
good if you're good at them like there's
some guys that are really good at what
you call basic is a classic yeah basics
a weird word and people get upset when
you say they're jujitsu is very basic
but some of the best guys ever have what
you call basic jujitsu it's not that
it's basic it's just they have only a
small amount of moves that they use but
they have them sharpen to a razor's edge
and it's not that they not they're not
capable of doing everything else just
some guys like there's guys that are
known for just having a guillotine choke
that's all they do
and you just got to avoid that [ __ ]
guillotine choke and they might still
get you with it you're some guys they
just win by triangle all the time only
by triangle and this guy's only win by
he'll hook there's like a bunch of
Hoosick the California kid Urijah Faber
oh dude that guy's hilarious did you see
him when he was on The Ultimate Fighter
sure okay
that thing that he when he gave that kid
[ __ ] early on when he was trying to make
this show uh-huh
and whatever he got caught and pick a
move whatever the [ __ ] rear naked
choke or something like that
and when the kid went the kid goes in
and he loses rear naked choke and easy
went out like Uriah just goes like yeah
he goes that's what he's known for look
him up and what I loved about that who
was like old school parenting yeah no
[ __ ] sympathy it's just like and I
thought was a very empowering thing to
do to that person like if he once he got
past the defeat like you'd be sitting
there going like yeah what the [ __ ] you
know that this is what the guy did let
him beat you with anything else but that
that's so easy and this is on me it's so
much easier said than done it's it's
it's incredibly difficult to stop
someone who's really good at something
if they're really good at oh I don't
think I'd have a problem Joe I rented
the last 20 what's the wrap-up I do bike
an hour here so like Kimmy all all
things Joe Rogan where we can see you
any UFC things coming up he we talked
earlier there's this giant one giant one
in Madison Square Garden because the UFC
was illegal in New York for 19 years and
it was all because of corruption this is
a funny story the culinary Union the
guys who used to own the UFC they sold
the UFC but the guys who used to own the
UFC also own station casinos they own
Red Rocks and they owned a bunch of
different casinos like I think 22
separate casinos maybe even more and all
their casinos were non-union and this is
a vote by the the casino themselves like
they got paid well and I guess they just
decided look we don't we don't need to
be Union so the culinary union was
trying to muscle the owners of the UFC
into going Union and so the way they
would do it is they mean they have a
bunch of different things they do
they'll stand out and take a culinary
Union is drunk they're huge they're huge
and they got those knives they managed
to keep the UFC out of New York and then
one of the guys it was in their pocket
got arrested for corruption he was the
main guy that was keeping the UFC out in
New York he went down last year at a
corruption and right after he went down
they passed it in New York State because
it was passed in every city and they
they told the public that it was all
that human cockfighting exactly I don't
mean while they had cake boxing boxing
everything else was legal but they
wouldn't let the UFC in
so finally it's legal now and now that
it's legal and also there's new owners
so the culinary Union doesn't have a
beef with these new owners because they
don't even have any casinos and the the
new event that they're gonna put in
Madison Square Garden has three world
title fights for former world champions
three different fighters who have fought
for the title before I mean it's a
[ __ ] unbelievably stat car race it's
the greatest card in the Economist fight
Conor McGregor's fight Nettie Alvarez
it's a it's two - there's three title
fights but there's two champions in the
in the final Conor is the featherweight
champion Eddie Alvarez is a lightweight
champion and if Connor wins will be the
first guy to hold two titles
simultaneously in the UFC how do you get
in that Conor McGregor shape is it too
late for me at 48 no no you can do it
two more he's just I give you a pillow
MA I'm gonna give you a pill I'm gonna
give you an ass I'm gonna give you a
mind set I'm gonna teach you take the
mindset you can't just [ __ ] I had
[ __ ] hope he's like your [ __ ]
remember Tommy Hearns he liked that
level shredded where Tommy was like a
6-foot tall [ __ ] middleweight yeah
somehow he could make like what is
middleweight 140 well he was 147 when he
fought Sugar Ray Leonard it was
welterweight romani yeah unbelievable he
was just like just like it was like you
drew him yeah like how do you get that
[ __ ] shred we had that tiny waist and
big broad shoulders and a ridiculous
right hand that reach him when he
knocked out Roberto Duran that's sick it
was a hook right I think it was a right
hand he face-planted them I think he hit
him with a bunch of things but I think
he hit him with he dropped him twice but
then he faceplant on with a right hand
where Duran just felt like a tree yeah
that like Pacquiao death yes exactly
like Marquez
so the Conor McGregor is not in the best
shape this is what's interesting I mean
he's obviously in great shape but he's
got a problem with his endurance that's
one of the things that makes this fight
interesting like he got tired I heard
you saying because he has explosive
movements he uses up a lot of energy
he's so [ __ ] fast he's so fast and so
explosive that when you have that style
of fighting
it's like sprinting whereas Nate Diaz
the guy fought was more of like a
marathon runner like Nate I love
nay's awesome and so is brother Nick but
their style is more like they don't go
100% they don't use a hundred percent of
their energy with every punch they're
more like 60s maybe 70% and they're
always they're always fresh and they do
a lot of marathon running they do a lot
of triathlons and they're always doing
the endurance work so the their
endurance is a big part of their ability
to recover and push a pace that most
people can't survive from so Conor is
not that guy like Nate it's like towards
the end he did a lot of looking at the
clock did all the running away - yeah it
had a reset you ran it literally ran
away from him and reset and you know
it's smart that reminded me when - when
I first did stand-up and Steve sweetie
was late and I was on a material and I
just kept looking at the back door lazy
counted I remember those days that was
at the Brockton the Brockton Knicks
comedy stop remember then you stood up
on that like was like you know those
awful stages where it was a really small
stage like a giant it's like he was
standing on top of a [ __ ]
refrigerator for whatever reason and
you're like looking down on the people
it was almost like this Andy Kaufman
like talk show desk but it was the stage
I don't know if I did Brockton I don't
know if I did - Kowloon I think by then
it might have been gone I did I did the
the Randolph I did Brockton Framingham
and then I think that was it for the
Knicks and then there was of course the
one downtown I never did Framingham
either I don't think I think that was
gone Kowloon of course the Lord's did
the Kowloon
I did giggles my Clarke's room did you
ever do that giggles under one Julie and
so anyway the Conor McGregor thing like
he's not I would say he's nothing I'm
the best cardio in the world you can't
say he's not in great shape because he
did go five rounds with Nate Diaz but
it's just it's not he's not the same
kind of shape they're like like Nick
Diaz has swam from Alcatraz five times
gets in the [ __ ] ocean with shark
infested Northern California waters
sweat and then now you have to be in
incredible shape to divvy out of your
[ __ ] mind to that - but you got to be
an incredible shape I got a buddy of
mine who just got done running the Big
Foot 200 he ran 204 [ __ ] miles 205
205 miles in 78 hours three days of
running three and a half three days of
[ __ ] wankers for
can wine yep it's called the Bigfoot 200
it's all document that's like running 60
to 70 miles a day oh yeah yeah yeah
you're less than a fifth yeah something
like that yeah something like that
numbers yeah 70 is 21 say 63 I like what
you're saying 18 he he's run hundreds a
couple of times he actually ran a
hundred in June to prepare for the 200
in August it's crazy
so his half marathon is a hunt is for
marathons basically he's a [ __ ]
animal I mean he runs uh does he does he
run with those feet sneakers no we can
see the toes now he's sponsored by Under
Armour so where's the Under Armour fat
tire shoes it's a nice cushiony shoe but
he's uh he'll run 14 50 miles a day
every day who came up with that Bigfoot
200 savages [ __ ] barbarians his
name's Cameron Haynes he's a
professional bow hunter and to get in
shape for bow hunting his bow hunting is
all about like climbing up mountains and
[ __ ] especially when you're hunting elk
hunt with that guy it's [ __ ]
exhausting I'm in pretty good shape not
in great shape I'm pretty good shape I
could barely keep up with him I mean
barely he's barely out of breath and I'm
[ __ ] dying I'm drenched in sweat
heaving and trying to follow it because
like for that one or anybody else I mean
the way he does it is a very unique he's
like one of the most successful elk
hunters in the world and one of the
reasons is shape because he can get to
places like you see an elk and the elk
goes over the ridge the key is you got
to get to that [ __ ] elk quickly
because it's moving over that Ridge
right so if you if you're looking at an
elk and it goes over the top of the hill
and goes to the other side the quicker
you can get to that the closer it's
gonna be that hill you got to get within
60 yards you don't know how how far it's
gonna move in the time it takes you to
get up there well it takes me maybe 10
minutes to get up there he'll take him 2
minutes
so about those extra eight minutes that
[ __ ] helps way out of range you go
down the hill after it it's gonna see
you you're never gonna get a shot at it
so he has a shot opportunity do you have
any like like the one that got away
sort of shot like you had it you lined
it up and whatever you exhaled at the
wrong time and you missed it and then it
took off that's an elk hunting you so
there I had five of those two weeks ago
there's five of those it
maybe six we hunted for a shot that one
with a rifle because we just couldn't
get close enough with a bow just five do
you feel your guide going like duty
you're gonna [ __ ] kill one here if
there's more pressure
oh that's just how it is elk hunting is
hard you know when you go and earn when
are you gonna go wild boar hunting again
I'm going with you
you and I are gonna go we're gonna
schedule something soon we'll schedule
something let's schedule something like
maybe after Christmas yeah get me an Uzi
and then I'm gonna I'm gonna get you yes
oh it comes running because those think
I saw when saying they're watching the
chef they're from Hell's Kitchen
god damn and I said his name early I'm
the worst yeah you made his scrambled
eggs again this morning my wife [ __ ]
loves him what kind of scrambled eggs oh
dude he [ __ ] he puts this what he
does he first of all he gets he gets the
pepper pot a little pan going a little
olive oil put some tomato still on the
vine man there was some mushrooms he
just lets that [ __ ] sizzle and then
he takes three eggs and like a dollop of
[ __ ] butter puts it in there doesn't
mix it already puts it on the flame and
then he starts mixing this thing around
he talks about all the chemistry you
don't want to mix it before you put it
in there doesn't put any salt in there
cuz some reason that does it he's like
on a Heath now off to hate you see there
and you have to do it cuz they hate it's
in here I watched it a zillion [ __ ]
times when I'm watching this he eats in
the pan hates in the pan so that's the
one thing that I learned I learned from
this guy chef Roy who did Roy Choi who
started the whole gourmet food truck
thing I did like Favreau's doing the
shooting this thing and I went over
there and I got to sit he taught me this
[ __ ] about the grilled cheese sandwich
and what I learned about these guys is
dude it's all controlling the heat like
my host [ __ ] it's just like medium high
I'm like medium high for ten minutes
it's like you're not cooking you just
stand-in there like a [ __ ] bouncer or
some [ __ ] it's like so he got emulated
so he does all of that and when it gets
to a certain level of coming together
then he takes his creme fraiche and puts
it in there what is creme fraiche I
don't know what the [ __ ] it is but it's
delicious right and then you get it you
bring it back back on the heat and then
salt in right he puts that [ __ ] in you
go and you just keep stirring this
[ __ ] thing and it almost looks like
it's water you don't think it's done you
tasting like oh my god this is great
then you
take it off right no wait you chop up a
little bit of dill you sprinkle it up
you mix it in there and then the by then
the sourdough toast pops up a little
olive oil on that he put the [ __ ]
scrambled eggs on that with the [ __ ]
tomatoes and the mushroom give it to
your wife over over but then they love
it and then they keep telling you to
make it you just like let's just do the
old scrambled egg with the cheese in it
I got to get you some eggs we have our
own chickens I have 23 chickens yeah how
long can they lay eggs before you have
to [ __ ] retire them well they just
stop laying eggs after a while but in
you spoon right no I just let them live
they just they just live and then they
die I've had a bunch just die how do you
know I've had chickens for now I want to
say five years somewhere around there
four or five years maybe five years and
they just [ __ ] die sometimes I've had
like but I have some of them that are
like five years old that are still five
years old I just picture this chicken at
his desk
you know the seminal classic 1950s don't
we do [ __ ] up up [ __ ] heart attacks
it was terrifying why does everybody's
heart just [ __ ] stop yeah and they
were all eating bacon and [ __ ]
martinis and all this [ __ ] I had no idea
and that was back when they you know
they had no respect for martial arts it
was all like I'll tell you nothing
stronger than a good old Sunday punch
and they'd be sit there eating [ __ ]
steaks and people were just dropping
yeah right and left like dropping dead I
know you like when conspiracy theories
you like a good conspiracy theories but
I like a good one the good I don't like
Sorokin lumped in with people who have
silly understand that here's a real why
don't we move on it was in the New York
Times they proved that scientists were
paid off by the sugar industry in the
1960s oh yeah absolutely they were paid
off to make saturated fat the culprit
for all these diseases and fat fat
people and heart attacks when it was
actually sugar I'm 11 distilling the
blame away from sugar and pin it on
saturated fat so babies scientists bacon
is actually not bad for you saturated
fat is actually not bad for you there's
a giant illusion that cholesterol
everybody things to collect all your
cholesterol is high dietary cholesterol
barely moves the needle on blood lipid
it's blood lip it's like when they
measure your diet when you're bent
measure cholesterol in your blood has to
do with a lot sounds great to me now if
you're also a stand-up comedian you're
not lying you don't have a white lab
coat on like I'm sitting like okay just
a Rogen thing what good what gives
people high cholesterol is first of all
the LDL cholesterol HDL cholesterol is
good cholesterol and bad cholesterol and
you can have high of wamba's if you have
higher the other one it balances each
other out I'll send you a podcast if you
have the [ __ ] the time to listen to
it it's a concern you can sit there long
enough via ferret it's hard it's hard
it's hard to sit down and listen to this
stuff but this guy Chris crushers on my
podcast who explained it all in great
names of all time Chris Kresser
but anyway it's not cholesterol Terry
look if you have high blood pressure or
dietary cholesterol or high David
Letterman Dave lemon let me do an ounce
of fat on him and he needed open-heart
surgery yes yeah yeah a lot of that's
hereditary some people just get a [ __ ]
roll the dice just like some kids are
born with leukemia I mean it's just a
it's not something you did so I like
them in smoking since there were a fetus
you know my big Fitness thing is I'm
big-time into body weight exercises so
I'm trying to get myself strong enough
to do a front lever it [ __ ] 48 years
away from the front lever is basically
you hang from the chin up bar you bring
your legs straight up and you hang in
there like a [ __ ] table and you got
to put partyi weight behind the bar so
there's all of these exercises to bring
that so you just can't imagine you know
do you remember planking yes just
imagine if you did it on your back
you're laying on your back in the air
but you're hanging from the chin up and
the legs are straight out like that okay
yeah so I've been [ __ ] with that for
like months trying to build up the
strength and I got myself to the point
cuz the whole thing is you got to be
behind the bar right and what's great is
I got this big head so kind of [ __ ]
you know there's a lot of weight already
behind the bar plus so I've got him a
point now where I can actually like I
used to be almost hanging upside down
and then gradually you can kind of bring
you have your legs in a ball so like the
weight is basically underneath it and
I've gotten to the point now or I can
just start to extend one leg and then I
fall to the ground ain't bad I'm gonna
get there though you'll get there
I just want to bust that out one time
because I got a buddy with mine
he has a bet with me that when I'm 70 I
can't do 10 pull-ups why so just a
[ __ ] 70 no when I turn 70 70 we have
to catch the better yes as long as you
just keep going you get that's the thing
it Stallone's in the 70s yeah but if I
don't sit here you do 10 push-ups right
so the chin-ups if I don't have that bet
I don't have that [ __ ] you so it's a
great carrot that I'm chasing there I
understand yeah you could do that has
nothing to do with age you can do that
move doesn't have to do with butter do
bacon and [ __ ] like that lifting just
kind of you know the best way to do it
honestly start doing bodyweight
exercises do a lot of chin-ups and stuff
like that but do them really slowly
that's one of the best ways to really
develop like serious strength like a lot
of people like to do chin-ups they like
to do those like kipping chin-ups you
see in CrossFit what I like to do is
what's keeping like you go like you kind
of like kick up and you kick up that's
like cheating
it is like cheating but it's people who
are there back on the back price but
it's a hard workout if you do a bunch of
them but it's just there's a lot of
criticism why does CrossFit have to be
done in front of everybody why can't
they just stay in their gym why are they
always running up and down the street
like look at us we're working out
because it's like look at us we're
working out Church nope nope you should
rub it in their face they're like vegans
in a lot of ways I want you to know what
they're doing you know it's like like
that's the that's part of the whole
thing it's like you become there's a
whole article about that about its
replacing religion for a lot of people
they become tribal and you get involved
in these group like group activities and
you you identify with that group like
you become a crossfader or you become a
vegan or you become a lot I mean not the
same thing wrong with people I won it
was like the gym is a good garage door
it's wide open there making all this
[ __ ] noise and it's like yeah I work
out too you know I I have the door
closed listen to a little Iron Maiden
lately but that's part of the fun of it
they want everybody to know they're
doing it so you walk by a Wow Billy's in
shape you know look at that look at him
he's [ __ ] lifting he's doing well
I've been like Bernard says haven't
breakfast and like outside cafe and all
some 20 these maniacs just run by get to
the corner and then they run back the
other way you just want to [ __ ] throw
your pancakes out him well it's worse
what if you're walking and they
[ __ ] almost run you over like hey
[ __ ] this is not a gym okay this is a
sidewalk like don't this is not it's not
a place for you to conduct your class
maybe it's like do anything like they
think that treadmills take up too much
energy no I think you're right so they
want people to know what they're doing
and they don't have the space you know
then have a track so they just had to
use a sidewalk you know I've seen that
I've seen like groups of people run up
and down streets it's [ __ ] stupid yes
it does in Santa Monica I was [ __ ]
laughing stupid
mountains but CrossFit itself what it
does is it gets people to get
competitive and when they get
competitive the good thing about it is
like there's a bunch of people around
you you're all pushing each other the
bad thing about it is a lot of people
their form falls apart when they start
doing high repetitions and they get
competitive with it then they start
getting injured I know a lot of [ __ ]
people that have hurt themselves doing
crossfit Oh what bells people always
[ __ ] themselves up right behind in there
baby yeah I don't [ __ ] with grab one of
those these gonna do them slowly and do
them with correct form the beautiful
thing about kettlebells is you can get a
great workout with a light kettlebell I
could get a great workout with a
35-pound kettlebell just light
kettlebell moving it slowly controlling
in every step of the way and you can do
all sorts of exercises go from one to
the other one to the other and you give
up you get a full body workout that
works it's actual functional strength
like it'll apply that I found these in
the reservation with I'm going all
old-school I got those atomic holds you
like that American ninja [ __ ] those
little [ __ ] look like little
cannonballs that's great I got those
hanging from my ceiling and I'm trying
to get the ones that look like the
nunchuck handles and I [ __ ] went to
order the thing and it never came and
then they sent me an email going like
did you still want them it's like yeah I
order to go to rogue fitness rogue
fitness comm they have all that crazy I
got that's what Iraq through those guys
okay and I got a speed bag and then I'm
gonna get those Swedish blasts and see
if I can get it myself up to be able to
do a [ __ ] human flag oh [ __ ]
well I like the [ __ ] where I'm working
towards something I can't just get on an
elliptical every day like I'm doing a
half hour and the big thing is what's my
new playlist cuz I will get bored
shitless with that but I feel like with
the speed bag you know I suck at that
but I'm getting a little bit better at
it
I'm like learning some I you know it's
funny my wife wanted it I wasn't man
enough I didn't want to have them think
but look at there's something cool about
doing it but do you know like Julio
Cesar Chavez didn't even know how to do
that it's kind of useless for boxing it
gives you a little bit of endurance for
your shoulders but when the [ __ ]
might drink punch somebody like this
imagine someone stood in front of you
punch them like this I think it was to
build up it was supposed to your timing
and also build up your arms you keep
your arms I'll shoulder in the head yeah
right but Julio Cesar Chavez it's
hilarious his only greatest boxer of all
time and he always used to laugh because
he would like try to do it and he
couldn't do it thank you
everybody everybody I mean he's a
[ __ ] monster listen dude I'm trying
I'm just trying to get in the eye I wish
to go to Gleason's Gym and they and they
knew I was there and they call me
billary swank you know because I'm
Million Dollar Baby it just come out oh
no we had a great time Charlie Murphy
once again gave me they gave me no it
gave me the lay of the land
Charlie goes you going down eggsy ok he
goes you're gonna be down there about
three weeks bad Charlie Murphy he goes
someone's gonna come up to you be like
how long you been boxing Joe nice once
you get in the ring I'm not getting the
ring yes he wants to go in there and try
out all the [ __ ] that he doesn't have
the nerve to try against a professional
fighter and you're gonna get [ __ ] up
right exactly three weeks whatever [ __ ]
he said on the nose this [ __ ] this
guy comes up black dude from Brooklyn
starts coming up to a white guy stand-up
comedian from the suburbs going oh you
nice man you can fox i just started
laughing get the [ __ ] out of here I'm
not getting the ring with you when he
[ __ ] laughed and walked away and I
told Charlie thinking he would laugh you
know Charlie's just so [ __ ] real deal
he just [ __ ] told you I told you
Charlie Murphy is one of the best guys
of all time I did that Maxim tour with
him I got to know him we did 22 dates
together yeah he's a [ __ ] great guy
and I really loved that dude I really
know one of those guys my [ __ ] phone
were in the toilet I lost his [ __ ]
number so imma be able to call him I
think I got it I give to you okay yeah
we got a rap dude sitting like 9 million
hours of traffic Joe you're the [ __ ]
best you've been one of the top comics
for what 20 25 I mean [ __ ] year since
I was in Boston when I saw you at the
kowloon and you did your Tigers [ __ ]
bit
which sounds like oh it's just targets
[ __ ] through the distant noise you
made of the the tiger was [ __ ]
unbelievable I still remember you yeah
bit making fun of the chicks out there
with the hair like a giant oh my god
you're [ __ ] monster so I'm so happy
for you
that yeah you've got another special
that's out on Netflix is called
triggered please watch it if you love it
please rate it so you know stay on the
front whatever that [ __ ] scrolling
thing is and and that's it man you're
gonna hook me up with some elk me [ __ ]
you right thanks but I really appreciate
you having me I'm not worried and I feel
the same way about you man you're one of
my all-time fish we're gonna have a big
hug alright guys thanks for listening
alright what's up bill burr here alright
how great was that ah the great chill
robe and finally got him on after 9
years of doing my [ __ ] podcast
finally got him on and I didn't do any
of the advertising because I knew that
it was gonna be too interesting to sit
there and talk to that guy so here's a
little bit of advertising I know what
you think it out sizing that's boring
well not all right here we go we've got
a new one here C so C so se e so C so
[ __ ] you man alright C so is the place
for comedy they won't tell you how
amazing they are but I will evidently
see so is amazing its comedy for comedy
nerds by comedy nerds see so spelt si
eso se ESO is the new ad free streaming
service bringing you hilarious original
specials hand-picked classics weeks of
stand of the minute [ __ ] that mine on
there and not pay me here [ __ ] hand up
pitch to pick classics weeks of stand-up
specials and more bin jabal kana big
comedy anytime anyway
see so every episode of SNL ever really
Jesus this is a big [ __ ] thing cuz
those guys those guys hoard those
specials yeah those episodes including
new episodes the day after they air the
Tonight Show Starring Jimmy Fallon Jimmy
Fallon from New England I get did so
great and Late Night with Seth Meyers
the day after they
and they even have classics like 30 rock
Parks and Recreation and Saved by the
Bell
now those are already classics
you see Saved by the Bell even British
comedies like the original office with
that dangerous guy Ricky Gervais Saul
what's he gonna do it the Emmys break it
up the entire Monty Python catalogue the
it crowd and Steve Coogan as Alan
Partridge discover the next big names in
comedy and watch the icons before they
made it before they made it big like
louis c.k chelsea peretti amy schumer bo
burnham and so much more critically
acclaimed originals an exclusive content
like harmon quest created by comedian
dan Hyman and funny as hell a variety
show featuring such comedians as Jim
Jefferies ah Jim Jefferies and Hannibal
Buress
if you're serious about comedy you got
to go to see so stream at any time Jesus
[ __ ] Christ we get it see so is ad
free and it's just 399 a month that's
less than you paid for the latte or
artisan cold brewed coffee you're
holding right now and right now my
listeners can try see so free for two
months when you use promo code bird at
the checkout at any point they gonna say
what see so stands for see so seriously
ignorant egos [ __ ] Oscars I don't
know shows what you can get in shows you
can't get anywhere else from critically
acclaimed original series to all 40 plus
years of SNL see so it's the only place
that offers every episode ever made and
the new episodes the day after they air
just go to see so calm right now to sign
up for too much for free for promo with
the promo code bar check out that see
SOCOM promo code BRR Joe just for the
[ __ ] SNL alone that's great
alright a speaking of Joe Rogan here's
this company on it on it has a new
product it's called emulsified MCT oil
what the [ __ ] is that what we're gonna
tell you MCT oil is one of the fastest
sources of clean fuel for the body and
the brain it's one of the best ways to
power up your performance and
Kickstarter wait
management program and I should do that
rub it right on my stomach there are a
lot of MCT oil brands out there but none
there's none like the emulsified MCT oil
from on it
what's emulsification that's like when
you got balsamic vinaigrette just
sitting there okay and the [ __ ]
vinaigrette goes away from the balsamic
or vice versa or whatever and you [ __ ]
freakin up and all of a sudden it's been
combined it's been emulsified you get it
it's like a carburetor when you got the
air in the fuel mixture and it creates
that foam that you can't drink but it
looks like a latte that's emulsification
emulsification available in three
delicious flavors coconut vanilla and
strawberry Jesus Christ that's me right
there coconut head vanilla skin
strawberry pubes emulsified MCT oil
mixes like a cream easily in your
morning coffee without the need for a
blender no mess no cleanup you can even
mix it into your favorite food liquid
Billy red face right here from on it
right now if you go to on accom onn i
t.com slash burger you can get on it's
emulsified MCT oil for 12% off that's on
it Oh n n8 e dot-com slash burr to get
emulsified MCT oil for 12% off any and
for any reason if you don't like it
they'll give you money back no questions
asked you got nothing to lose
go to on accom slash burn now and get
and get on it okay what do you got left
Jesus Christ I get out of breath from
reading out loud that's how dumb I am
alright SeatGeek
ok buying tickets online for sports and
concerts has been a confusing process
for a long time no there's nothing
confusing about it it cost a [ __ ]
fortune it's always hard to find the
best deal for that game or show you want
to go to and none of those older ticket
sites want to change that but SeatGeek
is different they've come along and
created an amazing app and website that
makes it easier for then f than ever for
fans to buy and sell tickets eek-eek
does all the price comparisons for you
by searching multiple ticket sites and
ensuring that you get the best possible
deal and C key quants to help you get
the best move the best bang for your
buck that's why even ticket that's why
every ticket on C key
is given a grade based on value you'll
immediately see any under price seats
and be able to find the best deals that
fit your budget best of all my list is
get $20 $20 rebate off their first seat
geek purchase to get your $20 rebate on
tickets download the seat geek app go to
the settings tab and click Add and add a
promo code enter the promo code barbie
you are RFC geek will send you $20 off
after you've made your first ticket
purchase download the seat geek app and
enter the promo code birt'day Jesus I
was doing all right there oh jesus here
we go
our old friends here everybody here they
are returning once again old zip are you
hiring are you hiring do you know where
to post your job to find the best
candidates posting your job in one place
ad isn't enough to find quality
candidates if you want to find the
perfect hire you need to post your job
on all the top job sites is it hard no
it's easy with all [ __ ] zip Crudup
dot-com you could post your job to 100
plus job sites including social media
networks like the Facebook like the
Twitter all with one single click there
find candidate and find a candidate in
any in the city or any industry what
find candidates in any city or industry
nationwide just post once and wash your
qualified candidates roll in like all
that hot pointed out ray or in Florida
to zip recruiters easy-to-use interface
no judging emails no juggling emails or
calls to your office quickly screen
candidates rate them and hire the right
person fast find out today why zip
dot-com has been used over one by over 1
million businesses and right now you my
listeners my listeners can post job on
zip Rick for free by going free by going
to zip recruited are calm / / that zip
recruiter calm / / one more time to get
free go to her set Rick
from third com / / alright next one flat
stand final sorry that's getting
obnoxious I know but there's only so
many with different ways to read alright
all Jesus its tracker we're all losers
Newsweek reports the average American
wastes 55 minutes a day looking for
things they own but can't find share a
story when you've lost something you
need it yeah I lost my soul when I
[ __ ] do something like that just give
me the copy and I'll [ __ ] read it oh
yeah I remember the time I couldn't find
my mittens oh boy a snowball fight
coming up I get it you put this [ __ ]
thing on [ __ ] you don't lose it anymore
yet for some reason they're gonna write
10 pages of [ __ ] tracker makes losing
things a thing of the past and I'll tell
you how to get one for free in a minute
tracker is a coin size device that
locates misplaced keys wallets bags
computers dildos anything in seconds
just pair tracker to your smartphone
attach it to anything and find his
precise location with the tap of a
button it's that easy lose your phone
press a button ah there it is on track
of your phone rings even when it's on
silent tracker is finding over a million
cheese's don't look at me like that come
here buddy come here I'm sorry you just
look at me like dude I will [ __ ] rip
your throat out if I want to now it's up
on the couch that's all that wanted good
good all right trackers what am i
tracker is finding over a million
misplace items each day order yours and
never lose anything again listen to the
show get a free tracker Bravo with any
order go to the th e tracker comm and
enter promo code BRR
the hardest thing you'll ever have to
find is their website go to tracker calm
right now and enter the promo code bar
for free tracker what free tracker Bravo
with any order again that's tracker comm
promo code burp did anybody see that
[ __ ] ad on TV that was making fun of
Ohio State the way they go the Ohio
State University they were talking about
things that you state you're sick
they go are you sick of dramatic pauses
after football players say the name of
their University and they had this guy
like doing like cross-eyed and just went
like the Brockton Community College I
butchered it but you got to see it the
guy's performance on it is tremendous
it's as funny as how unfunny the way I
just did it look at you Cleo what are
you doing
hmm you want to go outside Cleo can I
get it a howl before we leave click get
off the couch get off the couch all
right here we go
the key is you just have to make eye
contact I'm gonna go for this Cleo do
you want to go outside Cleo
there ya go good girl all right I'll
talk to you later